we've covered a lot of scps on this
channel but trust us none of them have
quite the bite that this one does we
know you like the more intellectual
anomalies and this will give you plenty
to chew on in that regard while the scp
foundation wants to keep
scp-5940 a secret here at scp explained
we're going to give you the tooth the
whole tooth and nothing but the tooth
uh truth i meant truth this scp
thankfully isn't as existentially
threatening as a lot of the other ones
we cover but just because it won't send
you on an express trip to the pearly
gates doesn't mean it won't wreck havoc
on your pearly whites open wide and say
ah because today we're getting into an
anomaly that affects each and every one
of us tell us have you ever felt anxious
about your teeth ever had that weird
dream where all your teeth fall out or
even worse someone pulls them out does
the thought of us taking a hammer to
your teeth or them rotting away someday
and making you need dentures make you
shudder and cringe don't be ashamed the
answer to this question for most people
would be a resounding yes and that's
because of humanity shared psychodental
trauma don't know what that is well
that's fine too after all the foundation
has taken pains to hide all this from
you for fear that even knowing about it
might incur further psychodental stress
it's that kind of subtle but constant
creeping dread you experience in a
dentist's waiting room knowing it's been
too long since the last time you came in
and now you're fully anticipating him
saying something like well it's a real
mess in here i'm afraid we're gonna have
to take them all and i'm gonna charge
you double just because they look so
unpleasant if that feels grimly familiar
to you then you know exactly what we're
talking about today the scp foundation
searched long and hard to find the
source of this peculiar collective
trauma which ironically is a major
factor in people not actually visiting
the dentist more often and has found the
source in question to be as ancient as
it is strange to best explain exactly
what we're dealing with here we need to
take a trip to the north pole though
sorry to tell you that today's scp is
not in fact santa's workshop it's
actually the northernmost point of
inaccessibility a part of the world
that's nearly impossible to reach simply
by virtue of being the cluster of arctic
ice pack furthest away from any landmass
always moving and shifting but if
through some means you were ever able to
make your way up there you would find an
impossibly large pair of maxillary
incisors which in layman's terms is a
giant pair of front teeth so while there
may not be santa's grotto up there if
all you want for christmas is your two
front teeth then buddy you're in luck
incidentally these two giant teeth
embedded into the ground and dubbed
scp-5940 by the scp foundation are
connected to the two front teeth of
every human being on earth think of it
as almost a pair of giant voodoo dolls
but their effects on each individual
human are relatively mild that's because
the effects are actually distributed
across all humans and the more humans
there are the less damage to the
enormous pair of teeth will affect each
of us the problem is humans have eight
incisors they're the two sets of four
front teeth on the upper and lower jaw
and this pair of teeth covers only two
of them what about the rest well next on
our roster is scp-5940
let's join intrepid scientist and
explorer dr john e namel who has no
affiliation with the scp foundation on
his quest to find them dr namle and his
small team brave brutal colds and
obscene treks through ice and snow to
finally discover this grand creation
near the southern pole of
inaccessibility the point of antarctica
furthest away from the southern ocean
when he and his men finally arrived they
gazed upon the incredible pair of teeth
in awe a mighty set of mandibular
central incisors otherwise known as the
front teeth on the bottom jaw the
foundation believes that the only way to
truly solve the problems that scp-5940
poses is to remove the various teeth
from the areas where they're currently
lodged however the foundation doesn't
yet possess the technology or resources
to properly dislodge any of these
behemoths however the psychic
anticipation of the impending tooth
removal has caused the psychodental
trauma of people all over the world to
skyrocket in the meantime in a sense
it's like the entire world is sitting
outside the dentist's office waiting for
a prognosis and hoping that when the
dentist pulls out their pair of surgical
pliers they at least have the decency to
give us a hit of the laughing gas first
however the foundation has discovered an
interesting fact in the meantime the
effects of the teeth on the global
population can be slightly mitigated by
enacting certain forms of concussive
trauma on them and to perform this act
for the greater good of the earth's
psycho-dental condition dr john e namel
and those accompanying him made the
ultimate sacrifice knowing on a
subconscious level what they must do
they began to turn their equipment into
a kind of makeshift diving board above
the giant incisors once the board was
complete the adventurists each took
turns jumping off of it gaining speed as
they rocketed down towards the teeth
below as each of them hit the sharp
upper edges of the teeth they were cut
in half leaving a smear of red against
the shining white calcium the two halves
of their bisected bodies fell down into
the piles of frozen bones on either side
of the teeth space all that remained of
prior brave heroes who'd made their
final pilgrimage to the site of scp-5940
while none of these various expeditions
were in any way officially related to
the scp foundation the foundation
nonetheless extended honorary foundation
stats of merit to those who decided to
take the plunge for the collective
psychodental health of their fellow man
for
scp-5940-3 we have to go deeper
literally it's at the bottom of the
ocean namely it sits below point nemo
also known as the oceanic point of
inaccessibility the furthest point away
from land in the entire world's oceans
this next absurd pair of teeth some
mandibular lateral incisors lurk below
the churning ocean waves like uh well
there's nothing really like a giant pair
of underwater teeth is there thankfully
the position of these teeth have been
serendipitous not only does their
remoteness make them much harder for
civilians to just stumble upon but point
nemo has always been a popular
spacecraft graveyard this means that
during tests and sometimes even actual
missions the return trips are often
piloted towards point nemo to prevent
the risk of any errant spacecraft pieces
from landing in populated areas and
causing damage or death remember we
mentioned earlier that the foundation
encourages repeated concussive attacks
against the teeth to ward off their
psychodental effects here the pieces of
spacecraft blasting into the water
towards them fulfill that role at the
latest measurement 126 of the 263
spacecraft ditched at this pole since
1971 had successfully collided with this
particular pair of teeth giving them
perhaps the weakest output of
psychodental trauma of any of the
scp-5940 instances and while the
furthest point in the ocean from any
major land masses may seem about as
remote as it gets the last instance of
scp-5940 easily blows it out of the
water well not literally but if it did
that would be a wonderful example of a
problem taking care of itself wouldn't
it the last instance of
scp-5940 scp-5940-4
a pair of maxillary lateral incisors
live on the dark side of the moon yep
dentists and pink floyd fans of the
world rejoice you're probably wondering
while the first three pairs of teeth
clearly grew on earth why is the fourth
a pair of more lunar incisors studies
performed by the foundation on the soil
around the base of the fourth set of
teeth proved that they actually did
originate on earth they believed to have
split from earth during the incident
which formed the moon this means that
these teeth are literally older than the
moon and this also makes them billions
of years older than humanity so these
giant teeth don't look like our incisors
our incisors look like these giant teeth
so now we finally understand this
ridiculous threat to our collective
psychodental health move over scp-682
and step aside devour of worlds get the
hell out of my face scarlet king we
can't deal with any of you small timers
until we solve the global psychodental
health crisis posed by scp-5940
which elite heavy hitters have the
foundation put on the case to deal with
these enamel nightmares
meet the department of psychodentistry a
joint venture form from the
collaboration of the psionics division a
task force that specializes in psyche
scps the department of mimetics and most
importantly of all the dentistry
division you may be thinking why does
the scp foundation even need a dentistry
division that seems like a waste of time
and resources and if you're thinking
that you're not only wrong you probably
have horrible teeth the dentistry
division is the first and last line of
defense that the foundation has against
a plethora of toothy anomalies like
scp-5852 a strange phenomenon that
causes human teeth to grow out of the
bodies of cicadas or
scp-2450 a condition that causes
hyperdontia the excessive development of
teeth all over the bodies of mammalian
creatures with the infection being
spread appropriately through bites and
of course scp-478
a predatory moth-like creature that
enters the bodies of victims under the
age of 25 and attaches itself to the
soft palate in the upper nasal cavity
from there it would promote the
unchecked growth of teeth on the soft
palate of the victim but that's just
where it starts teeth develop all
throughout the mouth nasal cavity
esophagus and even the interior of the
stomach where the digestion of the teeth
leads to excruciating pain next time
your entire body is filling up with
teeth due to scp-478
you'll really regret underestimating the
value of the humble dentistry division
so what does the new department of
psychodentistry propose to do with
scp-5940
the ultimate in tooth-based anomalies
thankfully they have a plan that will
unfold over the next 79 years known as
the absolute tooth field in all
uppercase letters it's a three-pronged
plan that's sure to fully neutralize
this dental menace you see there's one
thing we haven't told you the psionic
relationship between scp-5940 and the
incisors of all of humanity isn't one
way while the giant teeth and what
happens to them can affect our teeth
what happens to our teeth can also
affect the nature of scp-5940
and that little fact is the key to the
absolute tooth field plan the first part
of the plan involves using mimetics to
make humans shun birth control globally
accelerating population growth to 4.2
percent per year for the next 79 years
this will lead to a population of 200
billion humans by the year 2100 the
second part will be using mimetics to
encourage every human to somehow
mechanically remove all of their
incisors and the third part will be the
most complicated of all trying to get
all these 200 billion humans to remove
the same incisors at the same time the
department of psychodentistry estimates
that this will create the sufficient
psychic force to finally pull the
various
scp-5940 instances from their moorings
and thus healing humanity's collective
psychodental trauma it is a brilliant
plan to take out a dangerous anomaly and
surely one trillion six hundred billion
human incisors is a small price to pay
now go check out waldo finds you
scp-4885 find him and scp-2430 immortal
hitler clone for more of the absolute
weirdest anomalies out there oh and uh
remember to brush your teeth twice a day
you'll thank us later for that